I just I just don't give a [__] myself I
don't give a [__] about an autograph
right I don't have no autograph I don't
have any pictures of any me and anybody
I don't give a [__] you know what I mean
n yeah I can imagine bro cuz the only
person that ever um the only person that
ever made me and uh Shaggy nervous to me
mhm was when we met Vince McMahon hey
that had to be sick Bro our [__]
mouths dried out like we were both like
and he was like hey who who won the Grim
Tim contest you know and that was like a
contest we were having back then you
know and we just looked at well I
remember you guys coming out um I mean
you guys are for people I mean I'm a
huge wrestling fan and you guys are also
very heavily uh aligned in the wrestling
world you guys have had your own uh The
Jug wrest what is it yeah you guys have
had your own Wrestling Federation [__]
yeah man we've been at WWE you guys have
been in W WCW U ECW um bro before I
forget you want to hear something crazy
M um my girlfriend MH three weeks ago
yeah she's like I had a dream you're on
stage with Roseanne Bar and I'm like was
like girl the [__] would I be doing on
Stage rosan bar you know what I mean and
it happened bro what it happened last 3
weeks and I'm going to post the text cuz
she sent me that in a text wow I'm going
to post the text with the you can see I
don't know if you can I'm put the date
maybe people just have to believe me I
guess unless it's somewhere on the phone
I don't know but I'm going show the
[__] te the date right and then the
picture how did you end up on stage with
Roseanne um I did a podcast uh for some
comedian friends of mine oerson did you
is it was it in Vegas yes skankfest
yes yes
bro Roseanne is a legend bro it was
insane that's sick
man I didn't get I played Seattle the
night before yeah okay no sleep at all
no sleep flew in had to meet my
girlfriend deal with all this [__] in
the morning no sleep I don't even know
what I'm going to I have no [__] idea
you know they're just like come on let
gank Fest you know and uh I thought it
would be podcast in in like a hotel or
something you know what I mean and I
didn't have no idea and they're just
lead me through and it's just getting
more lit and more lit and there's a
[__] boxing ring with two hotties
slugging it out and and there's like
tears of people hanging over the edge
and whatever and then they lead me
through and all a sudden there's like
what had to be like probably a thousand
people in this room and this huge crazy
chandelier beautiful Vegas [__] you know
the [__] people are screaming Rabbid
and and it's just a uh table in chairs
and they're doing a podcast you know
what I'm saying and the place is going
nuts and then they call rosan up you
know what I'm saying and then they call
me up and I'm sitting next to [__]
rosan that'll be on YouTube if it's not
already on YouTube son yeah yeah that's
I'm sitting next to Rosanne and it's
like how the [__] and and all I've been
eating all morning is mushrooms nice I
got some shrooms right there I swear to
you got some shrooms I got a pound of
shrooms right over
here yeah how hard have we been looking
for shrooms last week I got a whole
pound for you if you want it ever since
I went to [__] skankfest I love
listen brother I you're my man there's
like 3 lbs in that trash bag
[Music]
[__] but bro you're shrooming you're
[__] having a Time and then R sit
next no sleep no sleep right and I get
up there everybody's up on this stage
drinking and passing Blunts and I'm like
Double C and Coke you know what I mean
and it's 2: in the afternoon and it's
just as lit and and when we do the
podcast it's so lit right then they're
like we'll take it to the Green Room so
I'm going through this pack crowd it's
everybody's party it's music [__]
dancing Everybody smoke blown weed in
this fine ass establishment they take me
in the Green Room and it's the exact
same [__] thing just lit it's just
lit in the green room and it's dark and
there's a DJ and there's food everywhere
and I'm like What's the [__]
difference you know what I mean I've
taking mad pictures all everywhere out
there and I'm like oh Green Room [__]
yeah let's go yeah we go relax in the
green room it's justra the green room
and it's worse you know what I'm I was
going to ask you on the wrestling tip
man like you know like you said you you
guys I remember seeing you guys come out
as like like on I I want to say was it
on Raw [__] right man I took a stone
cold stunner brother you took a stunner
[__] yes I got stone cold right there
man sometimes I think I'm he's behind
your head sometimes I think I'm lying to
myself I'm like is that true Yes Man
brother you want to hear the story yes
he was
like I when we first met stone cold in
WWE he was like he sat down by me and
Joey in the arena nobody's in there yet
and he we just he's like kind of music
do you like I answered him then he's
like um what kind of um do you hunt I'm
like
no and he's like basically we had
nothing in common nothing in common with
Stone Cold nothing and it was just like
and then so anyway like probably two
month or a month later two months
whatever um he's like all right you know
how to take a stunner and I said yes he
said all right listen I'mma come out
there first thing I'm going to do is
kick you in the stomach and give you a
stunner or no he said the first thing
I'mma do is kick him in the stomach and
and give him a stunner I'mma pop him
turn around and you know you got it I'm
like yeah I'm I'm I'm number two I got
it you know what I'm saying and and so
he's like um you know okay and and he's
like are you sure you got it I'm like
yeah so then we go to the gorilla
position we're about to go out there and
he's like hey man are you sure you know
you know do you know how to take a St
I'm like yeah bro I got it he goes so we
go out there and first person he kicks
is me you know what I'm saying so he did
it out of order yeah and I wasn't even
expected and I'm like all halfway
turning around and [__] cuz I'm still
thinking we got to look like you know
what I mean yeah and I'm just like oh
you know what I mean and I took it all
shitty but I tried you know what I mean
and I'm just thinking I want to tell
shag take it better than you huh did he
take it did Shaggy take the stunner
better than you did Shaggy took
everything better better than me but
Shaggy didn't take the stunner oh he
didn't yeah he kicked the guy from The
Headbangers okay okay gave him a stunner
at you know he was whatever but anyway
yeah it was dope though man that's sick
so you got to hang out with Vince you
got to hang out with Stone Cold take a
[__] stun I need to hang with Vince
but you got to chop it up with him for a
second meet him say hi Oh yeah yeah and
and after that every week we see him in
the hallway and say hi or whatever were
you guys coming out like when you guys
did the ECW thing was this after they
joined um WWE or was this prior like
Indie ECW days say it again like when
you you said you came out at ECW right
yeah was this prior to them joining the
conglomerate or was this with yeah this
is the real EC so this is like
independent ECW the hot ECW where all
the stars came from Sabo Sandman you
knowu Philly Taz yeah at the at the uh
ECW Arena sick yeah man did you guys
meet Paul Heyman yeah I love Paul Heyman
I love him too he's my favorite I think
he's like my favorite character I I
think he's the greatest manager ever I
think he's probably the most talented
man in pro wrestling the best mic work
ever yeah did you see his promo recently
where he was crying outside of Roman
Reigns locker room no oh my God it's art
I I haven't seen anything lately it's
good is it yeah so he's Vin's gone now
right yeah they sold to uh UFC but yeah
the the company so they put a big it's
it's like a a UFC and and and WW are now
owned I think
it's they have a TKO is the name of the
parent company um and uh I think it's
better if Triple H is running things
personally I like what Triple H do does
man are so are you guys still throwing
Indie shows every once in a while yeah
who who's been the biggest I'm with
Billy corgan's NWA right now oh that's
sick I was to say for you guys cuz you
guys actually have like wrestling DVDs
out and [__] like if people ever want to
go like there's is it was it jugal World
Order uh JCW championship wrestling what
was the biggest wrestler that you guys
were able to have kind of come AC well
we had Ric Flair at the Gathering you
know what I mean you guys brought Ric
Flair to the Gathering yeah man wow yeah
and what did he think of that [__] he
was supposed to host all night right and
uh he went out there one time he went
out there another time a [__] big ass
pop almost hit him he was like thank you
very much I'm get the [__] out of here
yeah he was out I'd be like yo before
you leave could you just give me one
chop to the chest
bro like can I take my shirt off and can
you make me pink real quick just chop
the [__] out of me pause you know what I
mean you met him no I would love to meet
him I met I met I've met a lot of
wrestlers I've interviewed a lot of
wrestlers but I haven't met Ric Flair
man [__] yeah man it'd be it's nice to
see him have this like Rejuvenation in
hip-hop culture like you know what I
mean like there's like uh the Griselda
guys and then obviously offset's got the
Ric Flair drip and [__] and now he's
selling weed called Ric Flair drift it's
it's pretty cool um I love it man yeah
know it's I love it bro it's amazing